الساعة 9 صباحًا في المغرب أيضًا، حيث
يتسابق رجال الإنقاذ مع الزمن للعثور على
المزيد من الناجين من زلزال الجمعة القوي،
حيث يستمر عدد القتلى في
الارتفاع، وقد تأكد الآن مقتل أكثر من 2100 شخص
بعد أن تعرضت البلاد لزلزال بقوة
6.8 درجة، وهو الأقوى
منذ أكثر من  منذ 120 عامًا، أرسلت كل من إسبانيا والمملكة
المتحدة فرق بحث وإنقاذ
للمساعدة، كما تم التعهد بمساعدات دولية أخرى
بالقرب من
مركز الزلازل في منطقة
الدمار والخراب مع
منازل في قرى صغيرة قللت من أكوام
الأنقاض، وقد أمضى الكثير من الناس
ليلة أخرى في الخارج الآن  يتزايد الإحباط واليأس
خاصة في
بعض المناطق النائية المتضررة بشدة، حيث
يمكنك شم رائحة الجثث في كل مكان، ومن
المؤسف أن السلطات لم تساعد
هؤلاء الأشخاص، وقد تلقى بعض الأشخاص
خيام المساعدات والمواد الغذائية ولكن بعض القرى
لم تتلق أي شيء خاصة في
المناطق الجبلية ذات
الطرق الخطرة آمل أن تظهر السلطات في
المجتمع المدني مزيدًا من التضامن
في هذه المناطق،
فقد زاد عدد القتلى الآن من مراكش، ولا يزال عدد القتلى مستمرًا
في الارتفاع، ومن غير الواضح في هذه المرحلة
عدد الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا مدفونين تحت
الأرض.  تحت الأنقاض ولكن عملية البحث والإنقاذ هذه
مستمرة إلى حد كبير
وقد تستمر لعدة أيام، وكان هناك
صراع خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
لفرق البحث والإنقاذ للوصول إلى
بعض المناطق الأكثر تضرراً من
زلزال يوم الجمعة، والعديد من هذه
القرى هي  تقع في مناطق نائية من
جبال الأطلس والتي عادة ما
يصعب الوصول إليها ولكن الطرق
تعرضت أيضًا لأضرار مما شكل
عقبة أمام إنقاذ المراهقين ولكن ما
بدأنا نراه الآن هو
انضمام فرق البحث والإنقاذ الدولية إلى الجهود القادمة.  إلى المغرب لتقديم
الدعم على هذه الجبهة، ولكن سيكون هناك
أيضًا تركيز على
جبهة الإغاثة الإنسانية أيضًا، وبالطبع فقد فقد العديد من
الأشخاص عبر جبال الأطلس عبر
المناطق المتضررة حول مركز الزلزال
منازلهم، وفقدوا
كل شيء على الإطلاق، ولذا
سيكونون كذلك  في حاجة إلى هذا الدعم لبعض الوقت
للمجيء إلى هنا في مراكش، ما رأيناه
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لمدة ثلاث ليال
متتالية الآن هو في الواقع عائلات تنام في
الشارع وتختار النوم في الخارج
خوفًا من هزة ارتدادية أخرى أو
احتمال وقوع زلزال آخر، وقد
قال الكثيرون إنهم  نحن خائفون للغاية من أن
منازلهم ليست آمنة وأن
هياكل مبانيهم يمكن أن
تنهار، وهذا هو الخوف الحقيقي للكثيرين في
جميع أنحاء البلاد في تلك المناطق التي
تأثرت بالزلزال ولكننا
شهدنا تدفقًا لدعم المجتمع
أيضًا  لقد كان هناك دافع حقيقي
للناس للخروج والتبرع بالدم، وقد
رأينا طوابير من الأشخاص يصطفون لتقديم
الدعم على هذه الجبهة، وبدأنا
نرى أشخاصًا يجمعون
العناصر المهمة لأولئك المتأثرين، ويقومون بتحميل
الشاحنات والسفر إلى المناطق تقريبًا
تأثرت بدعم
جهود الإغاثة الإنسانية ولكن هذه
ستكون عملية تستغرق أيامًا إن لم
يكن أشهرًا، وعندما يتعلق الأمر
بجهود الإنعاش، فإن جهود إعادة البناء
قد تستغرق سنوات حتى الآن. البشير سي إن إن
مراكش